E aí
[Música]
e há mais de três décadas no mercado
financeiro dentro de grandes bancos tem
ajudado milhares de pessoas e suas
organizações alinhar suas Finanças com
os objetivos desejados durante esse
tempo pude constatar que existem algumas
dores nesse processo a maioria delas diz
respeito à planejamento e cumprimento de
metas o próprio dinheiro a liderança e a
partir desta constatação eu quis muito
ajudar e com minha experiência e paixão
por este trabalho criei uma metodologia
que alinha estes três pilares
metodologia simples porém poderosa que
comecei a construir na minha infância
sou Sônia Santos Master coaching de
Finanças estratégicas palestrante
administradora e estudante de psicologia
vou contar um pouco da minha história
para que entendam porque sou
a meta essa palavrinha que muitos não
podem nem ouvir que já se sentem
estressados sou de Minas Gerais a filha
mais velha de paz que não foram
alfabetizados sou casada a 30 anos e mãe
de três filhos até os sete anos morei na
fazenda com meus pais e alguns de meus
sete irmãos porque outros ainda não
tinha nascido a separação foi doída mas
meus pais deixaram Claro o motivo de Aos
sete anos eu precisarmos separar deles e
morar na cidade para aprender a ler EA
escrever e a partir dali eu teria um
caminho a percorrer e esta tomada de
decisão seria para o meu bem meu
crescimento para que eu pudesse ter
melhores oportunidades que eles que
responsabilidade não que eu tenha vivido
uma história de dor para contar sempre
teve um lá
é que mesmo sendo muito simples era com
chegante nada me faltou tive um colo
muito caloroso tomar banho de bacia
disputar um lugar com meus irmãos em
cima do fogão a lenha para nos aquecer
nas noites frias acender as lamparinas
ao anoitecer tudo era normal para mim
para meus pais Faltava saber ler e
escrever saber o que dizia uma placa
quando passávamos pelas estradas o que
diziam os livros mas esta não foi uma
crença que os limitasse para prosseguir
em seus caminhos nas madrugadas eu
acordava e os dias saindo para trabalhar
mesmo Caindo o céu é suas cabeças de
tanta chuva entre relâmpagos e trovoadas
lá iam eles com suas capas pretas e
apenas um chapéu na cabeça para juntar o
gado e Ordem ar as vacas pois Av
a cada para entregar o leite para mim
era uma ação difícil me incomodava ficar
na minha cama quente gostosa e não poder
fazer nada por eles eu nunca houve uma
reclamação de que algo estava difícil ou
que talvez não pudessem entregar uma
tarefa Essa era uma meta para eles
também nunca reclamaram por não ter ido
à escola e também assim ter melhores
oportunidades levava uma vida simples
mas eram gigantes em suas ações o
inclusive asmos deles com a vida era
contagiante sabiam reconhecer quando
algo não estava dando certo não tinha um
medo das mudanças nem do sucessos e
insucessos e recomeçaram sempre que
fosse preciso
e eles eram meus heróis quando eu nem
sabia que existiam heróis cresci sabendo
que enfrentaria desafios também não
daquela proporção mas que os teria no
que eu escolhi esse fazer aqui seria
possível realizá-los tudo fazia sentido
para mim assim Aos sete anos foi-me dado
a primeira meta da minha vida aprender a
ler e escrever tinha prazo e data para
ser entregue e precisava me comprometer
a entregar deixaram Claros os motivos de
eu estar recebendo esta meta me
mostraram a importância do
comprometimento com os resultados o que
eu ganhar ia cumprindo minha neta e até
mesmo e superando e de que forma eu
faria isso sendo líder de mim mesma
liderando o que estava em meu retorno
para abrir caminho e chegar onde eu
preciso
Oi e desejar se era uma das minhas
primeiras lideranças porque liderança
envolve responsabilidade Inteligência
Emocional para estar com seus liderados
e administrar o seu dinheiro ou o
dinheiro da organização eu administrava
o dinheiro que me era dado para o lanche
da escola e era minha própria liderada e
minha própria equipe até então não sabia
o que era ser líder não tinha relação
com dinheiro muito menos sabia cumprir
metas meus pais deixaram claro que nada
me limitaria desde que eu me
comprometesse devia liderar as minhas
ações e as tarefas que receberia cuidar
bem do meu dinheiro e se resumia em
algumas moedas mas para mim era uma
verdadeira Fortuna mais tarde no grêmio
estudantil das escolas que ter cargo de
relações públicas uma forma que
encontrei
a funcionar com as pessoas nem sabia que
já era Network a palavra não era usada
nessa época lá estava eu fazendo porque
pessoas me Encantam me abrem portas para
ajudar a conquistar as minhas metas como
não receber crenças limitantes nem
negativas na infância quando comecei a
ouvir na escola ser rico pobre ter não
ter eu me achava riquíssima nada me
faltava eu tive tudo o que uma criança
precisava o essencial nunca me senti
menos em nada pelo contrário me sentir
poder ada na minha simplicidade se
dissessem você tirou a nota máxima eu vi
bravo e dizia assim tirei e comemorava
se dissessem que você está linda eu
dizia estou mesmo obrigada a autoestima
sempre foi combustível para minhas
realizações meus
e ela me proporcionava segurança nunca
sentia necessidade nem obrigação de
parecer alguém que eu não fosse eu só
queria ser fazer as coisas acontecerem
na minha simplicidade de uma adolescente
que amava viver e está entre as pessoas
interessantes gostava de compartilhar o
que soubesse Me Doar mas gostava também
de receber elogios se reconhecida pelos
trabalhos feitos ser reconhecida pelos
trabalhos feitos era o resultado nas
metas entregues nos prazos estabelecidos
crescer ciente de que metas nos norteiam
nos movem nos transportam a outros
níveis e isso nos motiva a irmos além do
que imaginamos e são momentos prazerosos
e felizes minha neta ela estudar então
eu tinha que ter
a frota saber se Líder administrar o meu
dinheiro que era uma fortuna mesmo sendo
algumas moedas Como eu disse
anteriormente Se recebi uma nota Nossa
não gastava de jeito nenhum guardava a
sete chaves porque já entendia o valor
do dinheiro ele era fruto de muito
trabalho dos meus pais de muitas
entregas e meu desejo e sonho era poder
retribuir muito em breve o investimento
o que fazia em mim agora por exemplo
minha meta é dar uma palestra que atinja
todos vocês sem exceção para atingir
essa meta eu me preparei procurei criar
um contexto para que me conheçam um
pouco mais entendam com mais facilidade
O que é o meu trabalho mas também
precisa estar aberta as rejeições em
outras palavras precisamos
em ciências de Que riscos existem estão
presentes no nosso dia-a-dia e naquilo
que nos propomos a fazer volto a minha
infância uma madrugada debaixo de uma
terrível tempestade meus pais saíram
como de costume para juntar o gado
quando depararam com 17 vacas mortas
debaixo de uma imensa árvore elas foram
dizimadas por um raio exatamente no
local que para elas seria o lugar mais
seguro para se proteger de uma
tempestade e o que esse exemplo nos
mostra ele nos faz sair de nossa zona de
conforto por mais habituados que
estejamos com determinado procedimento
precisamos analisar todos os pontos
criar estratégias para que possamos
entregar nossas netas no prazo
e quando os riscos a medicina a ciência
tem evoluído muito os aparelhos se
tornaram mais precisos mas até mesmo os
resultados de exames de DNA não vem com
100 porcento e sim 99,9 de probabilidade
de estar corretos então diante de nossas
escolhas buscamos probabilidades e temos
que nos preparar para mais de 100
porcento para atingirmos no mínimo cem
porcento do que nos comprometemos a
entregar pense que você precisa criar
estratégias para entregar até mais do
que isso existem crenças de que menos é
sempre mais mas eu acredito que mas
também pode ser mais quando precisamos
bater uma meta e temos paixão pelo que
fazemos Thomas Edison
e ele tinha neta de criar a lâmpada
quando perguntaram como se sentia por
ter errado 25 mil vezes Ele respondeu
que não tinha errado 25 mil vezes tiver
assim a possibilidade de fazer diferente
25 mil maneiras ser sábio não é ter a
certeza de que vai dar certo Sempre é
ter a clareza de onde se quer estar E
como está S ver literalmente no lugar
desejado saber como fazer o caminho para
chegar e para ter clareza você precisa
sentir paixão precisa se ver entregando
o seu projeto e recebendo por isso e
também se vendo fazer quantas vezes
forem necessárias independentemente do
que ganha com isso portanto visualize e
suas ações
eu nunca foi me perguntado o que eu
desejaria ser ou fazer quando eu crescer
nem na escola nem por meus pais acredito
que nesta época não era costume se fazer
essa pergunta ou talvez meus pais não
tivesse esse conhecimento mas eles
tinham me dado uma tarefa aprender a ler
e escrever e eu aprendi a amar ler e
estudar e quanto mais eu leio estudo
mais conhecimento eu busco mais pesquisa
tenho que fazer porque mais incertezas
eu encontro como senso comum no trabalho
de décadas dentro do mercado financeiro
com exatas eu sempre questionei muito as
incertezas mas não fiquei no
questionamento visualizei e pus em
prática a metodologia destes três
pilares alinhar metas exercer a
liderança
o dinheiro comecei assim ajudar nas
dores das pessoas mas queria ajudar mais
o que me levou a estudar programação
neurolinguística e Psicologia e
comprovei que podemos programar nossas
mentes e alinhar estes três pilares de
forma saudável e sustentável Você
conhece a história dos sapinhos vários
sapinhos corriam e havia um buraco
profundo pelo caminho dois deles caíram
dentro do buraco e Gritos e gestos
vinham lá de cima dos sapinhos amigos
dizendo que não seria possível sair
saltando daquele buraco era preciso
esperar a chuva vir para que o buraco
encher-se de água e pudessem nadar mas
um dos sapinhos Faltava só faltava
quanto mais eles gritavam e gesticulava
mais o sapinho saltava e o outro ficava
quietinho Esperando a chuva como usar
e sugeriam e o sapinho que saltava em um
impulso conseguiu sair do buraco quando
chegou a superfície agradeceu aos amigos
os gritos os gestos de incentivo a
motivação para continuar faltando até
sair só e os amigos perceberam que o
sapo era surdo percebia que gritavam mas
interpretou os gritos de outra forma
Precisamos ser surdos às vezes das
nossas próprias interpretações aos fatos
porque não deu ouvidos a quem dizia que
minha formação já bastava me capacitei
Master Coach na Flórida se treinamento
com Tony Robbins na Califórnia um dos
maiores Colts do mundo construa metas
arrojadas desafie-se e você perceberá o
gigante que é de outra forma não será da
sua capacidade o seu poder de realização
não tem
a 15 O que é seu de fato se tem ser Izar
Tenha consciência do que está
terceirizando de leg com consciência
pois os resultados são de sua
responsabilidade enquanto Líder você não
deve culpar o outro pelo que eles falta
pelas escolhas que não deram certo pela
carreira em que não foi mais sucedido
Entenda os motivos que levaram aos
resultados insatisfatórios visualize e
soluções e refaça o seu planejamento as
escolhas de quem participa do seu time
são suas Então os resultados são de sua
responsabilidade no colt muitos vem até
mim pensando que eu tenho respostas
prontas o que eu faço é provocar mostrar
probabilidades e nesse movimento levar a
pessoa a encontrar formas de fazer e ter
as respostas que estava
e no seu subconsciente Não crie
desculpas para você mesmo para o que
você não foi capaz de fazer isso pode
ser a destruição de seus dias cometas
sua vida terá mais sentido haverá um
alinhamento um equilíbrio motivos para
você executar o que precisa ser
executado parâmetros para crescer e se
desenvolver meta não é sacrifício então
o prazer da realização eu sempre quis
ser protagonista da minha história
visualizei meu futuro mesmo não sendo
perguntado o que eu desejaria ser
desejei ser uma executiva de sucesso do
mercado financeiro e me tornei atingir
minha meta falamos muito que precisamos
ter clareza das metas sai da claramente
Quais são as suas escreva se achar
melhor
e compra suas metas o mais rápido que
puder exercendo a liderança interna e
externa seja grato por isso construa sua
vida pessoal e profissional neste tripé
que são metas lideranças e dinheiro a
vida passa muito rápido parece que ontem
vivia a história quer compartilhei com
vocês mas já se fazem muitos anos então
para finalizar quero reforçar que os
melhores momentos são os de entrega
minha primeira meta cumprida foi quando
lhe para meus pais Aos 8 anos durante as
férias na fazenda o livro Robinson
Crusoé foi como se eles estivessem lendo
através dos meus olhos e hoje com
certeza ficarão orgulhosos Ao me ver
aqui para mim um sonho realizado uma
meta atingida e compartilhada gra
é